chaque jour que Dieu fait je descends en
enfer les mines c'est difficile vous
aurez 18 mois renouvelaable de
travail regardezle le petit nouveau
alors c'est not arabe tu sais comment on
nous appelle nous les mineurs non les
guul noir parce qu'une fois en Vaas
italien espagnol français ou arabe on a
tous la même couleur c'est charmon
mauvaise nouvelle tu fais descendre un
touriste il descendu à ton avis
professeur atint les 1000 mespè trouveré
quoi mon
trésor est-ce que c'est professeur selon
la légende une sorte de
Dieu
ah il y a quelque chose de vivant
làdedans on est tombé sur un truc qui
nous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dépasse